hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the haunted house of
horrors okay so I'm in the real world
again or the real world not the
nightmare land I really love having
guests over there was a time when little
Forrest things would come to visit and
sometimes I even made dinner for lost
Wanderers I would set the table and pass
the time in a conversation with them in
my head that's when I realized that more
than anything in the world I'm afraid of
the invisible so where's the diary now
I've got to find it quickly nothing else
matters
so this diary is in this house here here
it's in here I got to find it here I
guess I don't really know because
there's this weird world where he makes
up the rooms that whoa if any home in
any home you only need to wait for
sunrise no exceptions one simply cannot
go on if there is night inside I often
address the Diaries entries to myself to
my older self who one day would read
these entries it was just a game but now
I feel that a complete stranger has
penned these pages maybe you never know
a hunt huh you saying contra a good game
yeah okay well I've got to find the
pages of the diary before it's too late
the forest is at the end of its life it
used to be a rich biotope but now it's
dying I couldn't find any healthy new
growth the land has grown soggy too all
of the large species of animals have
died out all that is left are numerous
species of insects what about those
freakish chicken head things you've seen
before I distinctly remember some very
disturbing images of horrifying
creatures of ill-repute
oh I just noticed the clock isn't even
moved that's not supposed to be happy
is there anyone at are there people in
this house is anyone actually in here I
thought I always say if you don't see
something it doesn't mean it isn't there
the handwriting is made to look like
mine but it's just a little off I didn't
write this that's for sure well then who
did
I'm still confused
the clocks not moving and I'm hearing
noises aspect I see shadows lurking in
the darkness I don't know what is that
under that though thank you
what what happened I don't know what
happened why do lights keep going out
what is that thing under the blanket hey
Jesus man what is going on with your
life the story is being pieced together
very slowly that's so interesting to see
what corner okay I don't think I think
that was all the house so I'm gonna just
go ahead and get this I got two more
pages and I'm assuming yeah that's okay
that makes sense every time I hit that
clock the door opens but why why oh the
light went out in here something
actually in here or what okay never mind
I'm gonna agree moving on all right all
right all right let's hunt for the
little girl one of you guys said that I
needed to find her that's just what I'm
gonna do
go until I find her gotta keep an eye
out everybody stay sharp
Pepa thought uh she's probably enticed
by my wonderful ethnic dances let me
show you the dance of my people little
lady oh no Chris your people are sick of
that already
oh well look the pie out but okay so I'm
on the I out it's just like a barely a
little shadow that'll see who's that I
heard something was something knock
knocking out I hear little noises I do I
hear little noises
but what does it mean what does it all
mean I don't know I don't see any look
see anything
maybe deeper in the forest look if I
keep going one directional fear does
creaking woods nothing to be afraid of
let me tell you the scary story in the
dark the story of the moose man the
moose man is half man half moose some
guy some Canadian got drunk in the woods
and third going here that looks good a
her and made the Moose man and oh you
like the store Oh what the hell for this
come from
I haven't found a little girl yet is she
even out here or does I'm doing some
anyway the Moose man wandered the woods
alone raised by wolves and beavers at
the same time ah ha ha hi there what's a
matter
come here come here come here hey hey oh
ah she was there I saw her ah she was
listening out of my story of the moose
man anyway the moose man wandered the
woods for ages when he came across the
castle in the wind and he came across
the owner Alexander of brennenburg and
Alexander being a kindly old man took
him in adopted him gave him armor in a
new sward and gave him purpose and a
duty but then this young bryggen came in
by the name of daniel daniel was kind of
a douche but he was alright I guess I
guess I did I find her I did nothing
happened like before cuz before when I
found her before when I found her
something actually happened I don't know
I've been wandering these woods too long
I'm gonna just make her yeah I don't
know what happened I thought I I thought
I said I thought I found her I guess
maybe I did I'm not sure but okay tell
me if I did something wrong in the
comments of way I'll be able to read it
well anyway we're moving on deeper into
the madness of this guy's mind I don't
even know what this guy's name is
I don't call him Johan Johan give out a
bit
hahaha gaveta [ __ ] yeah that's his name
Johan all right it's no secret that
everyone else's oh I've already read
this yeah yeah yeah yeah hide and seek
okay let's get in here
let's get gon start our journey through
the darkness again looking for pages to
a diary you don't know if you actually
wrote seems like a good life to live man
we'll leave that light on why cuz I'm a
baller why okay good I'm gonna leave the
lights on just cuz I'm such a badass or
probably not yeah I really don't know if
you're not supposed to leave it on or
not I mean I know you can't see him but
yeah it's kind of probably problem
probably a problem I don't know like a
lot of things in this game I don't
really know the main purpose is oh I
thought I saw that me but that was just
the UH the things is the rails for the
downstairs ladder if you guys haven't
gotten this game yet that's okay I'll
keep playing it but you're missing out
this game is something special I'll tell
you creepy enticing interesting
intriguing and fun it actually is quite
one okay I haven't been able to find
anything of value where is that diary
could it be hiding somewhere here hey
where are you yeah that's right you're
not crazy for calling out to a diary I
know this place a neat little hiding
place any secret childhood stash right
over here is where someone used to hide
his little secrets wait what where what
do you mean what are you talking about
your eyes are closed
happened happened would I burned don't
happen he imagined up something but I
don't know what footprints dirt still a
bit fresh this is recent what is that
did I really walk through the forest in
my sleep well there's some new news wait
a minute
holy crap I just connected some dots
they're two sides of the same coin a
child could there have been a child here
I can't recall no I can remember anymore
I'm always forgetting things that's
right okay that's that's it he there are
two sides of what oh oh
real quiet anyway since I was the same
coin when he goes from one world to the
other he's both asleep and awake and I
don't know what the real world is that's
the thing that's the thing that's a
thing he's going between two sides of
his own mind he doesn't know which one
is real just like I don't um this
probably neither a real open your eyes
man open your eyes you're doing Lisa's
hiding place
okay can't it wait I can't hide there
whatever all right it's okay no monsters
yet but I'm sure that'll change dizzy I
just had to say something why did I have
this I nothing I just had to open my big
flapper flap my gums all over the place
until monster you're not gonna imagine I
get that a tenten tenten hi there buddy
how you doing friend Hey gonna why isn't
it quiet
hell no I did it for you shut up then
trap jack who's down there
are you wait what
use the monster what why what I don't
want to play with you uh I don't want to
play I don't want to play oh thank you
why can't I hide I did hide why what no
I didn't ever grow the double-layer
defense always works no no no okay go
ahead get it this isn't good
what all that I touched the box head
before it feels like I stepped on
something living would that do didn't
really affect me it doesn't
ah go away look oh you dick
why are you talking you're being very
not friendly many more you used to be
kind of helpful but now you're just kind
of not
this isn't god dammit you're joking me
right hey you know what good I'm out of
here I'm out of here I'm out I'm out I'm
out I'm out I'm out baby I'm out
I'm out of here I'm out of here I'm gone
maybe okay good
you stay away you stay far away until I
never see the light of day why do I hear
why do I suddenly hear crickets down
here why did I hear crickets down there
I don't know what I'm doing okay so far
I don't know what that thing of leaves
was not as creepy is the thing of
Boxhead black's goodbye it's not a
sinister voice it shouldn't be that as
creepy as it is right it shouldn't be
but it is
are you imagining something thank you
fine time times I've got give me time
baby I think I've gone through the
entire Oh what are you imagining up now
what are you making what are you doing
oh okay just more stuff that's good I
guess
is he still up there oh whoa
eyeball time to shut that out ha God
hold up way too close
oh that was way too close
oh the ghosty goo is like trolling the
first floor strongly imagine something
good yes yes I should I should I'd get
way too excited about this all right
wait what I didn't mean to hide no we're
almost done almost done almost done oh
yeah yeah yeah
huh there we go whoo I was worried for
his either yeah huh oh there was another
room to the left I thought that door
wouldn't open oh I didn't even see that
all right everything's alive this is a
game to be played in silence two hours
before sunrise gather the guests
everybody chooses a human for themselves
after that the guests should move
silently through the house all the
guests are focused on their own business
sooner or later you will hear a voice
here birdies gather around the marble
nest then everyone should freeze in
place if the rustling continues that
means the game is over and you should
stop immediately the invisible one is
among you once again these games do not
sound like fun however I have made it
through another night and I'm on the
other side again for the house what it
means I do not know I really still don't
know what it means but that is a mystery
for another day because I am all out of
time for now so thank you all so much
for watching click the annotations more
than use that I've done and as always I
will see you
this is ridiculous
see that one
but
places ah